R
HAVING ME ON.
LAWRENCE: THANK YOU.
AND JOINING ME NOW IS FATHER OF
KAYLEE STEVE GONCALVES AS WELL
AS FAMILY ATTORNEY SHANNON GREY.
STEVE THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOIN
THE PROGRAM AGAIN.
I MADE A PROMISE TO YOU THAT --
OUR AUDIENCE WOULD STAY ON THIS
CASE AND NOT LET THIS CASE DIE.
WE HAVE A COOLING OFF PERIOD
LAST WEEK AT A RESPECT FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
BRING THE TEMPERATURE DOWN A
LITTLE BIT, WHAT NEW CAN YOU
TELL US STEVE?
I KNOW WE HAVE THIS NEW
SURVEILLANCE VIDEO RELEASED BY
DIGITAL TEAM TODAY.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
>> THAT FILM --
TO THE FAMILY WE'VE HAD THAT
FILM FOR A WHILE.
I BELIEVE THE BUSINESS REACHED
OUT TO US DIRECTLY, AND AFTER
THEY HAD GIVEN IT TO THE POLICE
SO IT WAS KIND OF COMFORT TO US
BECAUSE IT'S JUST TWO GIRLS
HAVING A GOOD TIME TALKING
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, ASKING ABOUT
THEIR BAR TENDER AND JUST BEING
GIRLS ON THEIR WAY TO THE GRUB
TRUCK.
>> YEAH SO YOU DON'T STHAPT THIS
GUY ADAM THIS STATED IN THE
VIDEO IS SOMEHOW A SUSPECT OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
YOU GUYS HAVE KNOWN ABOUT THIS
VIDEO FOR A WHILE.
>> WE HAVE, AND WE ASKED AND WE
DID THE OBVIOUS DUE DILIGENCE
WHEN WE LOOKED INTO THAT AND WE
WERE PRETTY --
IT WAS PRETTY CLEAR THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL WAS NOT A PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION AS FAR AS THE
SUSPECT.
LAWRENCE: COIF WHAT CAN YOU TELL
US AS FAR AS THE INVESTIGATION,
CAR, DETAILS BEING RELEASED AS
WELL.
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
TO GET SOME ANSWERS FOR YOU GUYS
SO WE CAN GET THIS SUSPECT
WHOEVER IT IS IN CUSTODY.
>> THEY'VE KIND OF INFORMED US
THROUGH COMMUNICATIONS THAT THIS
THEY'VE CHECKED ALL OF THE
EASIEST PATHS SO LIKE IF THIS
INDIVIDUAL HAD THIS COVERAGE
STRAIGHT TO HIS NAME AND IT WAS
SOMETHING VERY QUICK THAT THEY
COULD LOOK UP IN THE AREA AND GO
RIGHT TO HIS HOUSE THEY'VE DONE
DUE DILIGENCE THERE AND ALL OF
THAT SO NOW REACHING OUT AND
THEY'RE GOING LOOK TO THE
COMMUNITY, SEE IF THIS
INDIVIDUAL BORROWED THIS CAR.
YOU KNOW, IT DOESN'T APPEAR THAT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY HAVE
REAL EASY ACCESS TO SO HE MAY
HAVE RANKED AND PUSHED NARRATIVE
SAYING WE CAN GET THESE GUYS TO
FOCUS ON SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
HELPFUL WHICH IS THIS CAR --
AND YOU KNOW, FIND OUT IF
SOMEBODY SAYS HEY YOU KNOW WHAT,
THAT CAR --
THAT LOOKS A LOT LIKE MINE, I'M
GOING TO COME FORWARD AND JUST
VOLUNTEER MY INFORMATION, AND
THEN, YOU KNOW, THEY CAN FIGURE
OUT IF SOMEBODY ELSE HAD
BORROWED IT OR IF IT HECK WHO
KNOWS.
>> STEVE WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
OFF AIR.
BUT ONE OF THE REASON WHY IS I
WANT TO BRING THIS UP IS BECAUSE
I THINK IT IS CRITICAL TO THIS
INVESTIGATION.
THESE A LOT OF THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE WERE TEENAGERS AND THERE
MAY HAVE BEEN SOME ELICIT
ACTIVITY THAT WAS MINOR THAT
THEY WOULD HAVE GOTTEN IN
TROUBLE FOR AND IT MAY BE
PREVENTING THEM FROM COMING
FORWARD.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO KIND OF MOTIVATE THEM
TO GIVE UP SOME ANSWERS DON'T
WORRY ABOUT ALL OF THE PETTY
STUFF FOUR INNOCENT LIVES WERE
LOST HERE.
>> YEAH.
I WANT KIDS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS SUCH A BIG CASE THAT
THAT --
THESE GUYS GUYS HAVE THEIR HANDE
FULL.
I WANTED TO GO OUT THERE TO TELL
EVERYONE WE SUPPORT WE SUPPORT
THE LOCAL POLICE OFFICERS SO
MUCH SO THAT WE WANT THEM TO BE
ABLE TO WORK ON THIS CASE.
I KNOW THAT THIS IS WAY OVER THE
NORMAL WORKLOAD THAT THEY
NORMALLY HAVE PLUS THEY HAVE
PATROLS.
THEY HAVE TO PATROL NOW THIS GUY
IS NOT CAUGHT.
SO --
YOU KNOW THERE WAS SOME RUMORS
THAT I --
CALLED THESE OFFICERS A COWARD
THAT WAS NOT FOR THESE OFFICERS.
THAT WAS FOR LAWYER THAT WAS
STANDING IN BETWEEN WHAT THE
LAWYERS WHAT THE OFFICERS WOULD
LIKE RELEASE AND WHAT IS
ACTUALLY BEING RELEASED.
AND I CALLED THAT INDIVIDUAL,
AND THIS WAS JUST ABOUT COMING
FORWARD SAYING THAT THE PROFILE
IS A MALE.
YOU KNOW, I FEEL LIKE AT A MONTH
WE COULD RULE THAT THAT'S NOT
GOING TO HURT THE CASE.
IT IS PRETTY CLEAR EVEN --
YOU KNOW THE CORONER SAID IT WAS
A VERY STRONG INDIVIDUAL TWO
PEOPLE HAD DEFENSIVE WOUNDS
OVERPOWERED THOSE PEOPLE SO I'M
TRYING TO STEER THE CONVERSATION
INTO A WAY SO I HAVE ANOTHER --
PERSON WHO IS GOING TO SCHOOL
THERE.
AND I DON'T HIM WALKING AROUND
THOSE STREETS IF IT IS NOT SAFE.
SO --
YOU KNOW, WE KNOW AS A FAMILY
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR, AND YOU
KNOW IF THEY SEE AN INDIVIDUAL
LOOKING A CERTAIN WAY I'M
TELLING MY KIDS YOU KNOW, STEER
CLEAR OF THAT.
I WANT OTHER FAMILIES TO KNOW --
>> STEVE THIS IS YOUR I'M SORRY
TO INTERRUPT YOU BROTHER BUT
THIS IS YOUR FIRST CHRISTMAS
WITHOUT KAYLEE.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
HOW'S YOUR FAMILY DOING?
>> TO BE HONEST WE'RE NOT EVEN
REALLY GOING TO HAVE A CHRISTMAS
BECAUSE YOU JUST CAN'T.
YOU CAN'T GET YOURSELF THERE TO
WHERE IT WOULD MAKE SENSE.
ONE OF MY CHILDREN THE YOUNGEST
ONE IS GOING TO GO STAY WITH
SOME FAMILIES BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE THE NORMAL TYPE
CHRISTMAS AND SHE DESERVES THAT.
BUT FOR US --
WE CAN'T DO THAT.
IT'S TOO CLOSE TO OUR HEART, AND
HOW DO YOU HAVE A CELEBRATION
LIKE THIS WHEN --
YOU LOST TWO OF YOUR FAVORITE
PEOPLE IN THE WORLD.
>> YEAH.
BROTHER, WE CONTINUE TO PRAY FOR
YOUR AUDIENCE AS WELL THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR JOINING THE PROGRA